les choses
et c'est une journée de deux fans en
fait le but c'est de s'amuser
on va s'amuser ça va être cool de
journée inoubliable alors nous sommes
sur la plage de l'étang salé les bains
pour la deuxième édition des jeux des
collégiens 2014 on a déjà eu les jeux
régionaux le 21 mai en lice et en beach
volley la semaine dernière le 11 juin on
a eu le
le beach-volley collège en benjamins
minimes et donc aujourd'hui c'est là la
finale gl les derniers jeux
départementaux des collégiens donc là on
a le aujourd'hui le sens de balle et la
lutte sur sable
alors le partenariat du conseil général
consiste surtout à nous aider sur le
paiement des
les bus des transports pour les
marmailles et puis bah tout ce qui est
organisationnel tout ce qui est les
t-shirts des jeux des collégiens pour
pour les gamins l'urss nous notre slogan
c'est plus que du sport faire du sport
ils vont en trouver dans le monde
fédéral qui est aussi un de nos
partenaires mais le côté éducatif c'est
que on va mettre l'accent sur le
développement durable par exemple
aujourd'hui la loi nef nous autorise à
utiliser à plage et en salle et qui est
sous sa responsabilité
on nous demandant de faire attention à
la végétation les patates à durand les
paliers les raisins mer etc mais nous
lasser de la rencontre c'est par ont
bien sûr il ya un classement mais c'est
pas la compétition qui compte c'est les
changes la rencontre
le/la le sport pour la santé ce qu'ils
ont vécu une fois ils savent qu'ils vont
s'amuser ils vont être entre copains
avec le pique nique tiré du sac le midi
ils vont s'éclater le soir ils vont
rentrer fourbus mais contents a qu'un
bon coup de soleil est prêt à remettre
ça l'année prochaine